Elden ring it wasn't shown at this
year's Game Awards so it might actually
be another six months before we get any
news at all but to pass the time we have
this competition bosses and art that
will help us to imagine this open world
title that we know precious little about
there were hundreds of entries to this
year's competition and as always it's a
huge responsibility to rank them all so
as you look through all of these
incredible entries please remember to
continually update your favorites in the
top right of the video player because
I'm curious to see what you will think
as well so without any further ado
please join me in imagining Eldon Ring
number ten
this is egg drill a manifestation of you
guitar sill the world trade all types of
art were accepted in this design
competition and pixel art was no
exception
[Music]
after the disappearance of the sacred
tree a girl decided to join the fight
countless he is defending the northern
forest had destroyed little by little
his own sanity but in the end the forest
was a part of himself and only the most
intense fire could burn the branches
that connect the lost kingdoms so the
top ten ended up being largely defined
by the categories that they scored 10
out of 10 in and this piece received 10
points for presentation thanks to the
short video and the tidy screen that you
see here while an overgrown golem boss
was a little bit common the pixel art
was excellent the folklore pulled its
weight and the mechanical arm referenced
to the olden ring trailer was
appreciated so congratulations on making
the top 10 number 9 Starchild by Daniel
acknowledge Starchild is one of the few
on this list that received full points
for technical skill the attention to
detail is crazy just look down to the
splash in the water the blood dripping
down his leg his hair whips away in the
wind and droplets of water even flying
away from his flailing necklace this
piece is insanely photorealistic and
that detail persisted across all three
panels and really helped to draw me into
the world and of all the entries I
believe this was the only frontrunner
that was inspired by fairy kind which is
folklore that spread throughout early
Europe specifically this piece was
inspired by the Starchild by Oscar Wilde
the story of a handsome boy who for the
first 10 years of his life believes that
he is truly the son of a star as he was
found deep in the woods as a baby
wearing a star amulet and a star cloak
in these images I'm showing he's been
taken in by the Fae small creatures that
worship Him for his beauty however like
them he becomes cruel and vain going so
far as to rip the wings of other small
creatures so he can wear them for his
own
across this location in-game Daniel says
that the player will hear a wailing in
the woods
very faint at first but getting louder
as he follow the direction of the cries
eventually you reach an opening in the
forest revealing this scene where an old
white-haired hag sits in a flat pool of
water crying and wailing this is the
Starchild's real mother whose unsightly
appearance infuriates the star child
causing him to lash out and initiate the
boss fight with you as the fight goes on
small fake Reacher's dart out from the
undergrowth while you fight to the
Starchild and if you as the player
eventually decided to spare his life
then later on in the game you can find
him enslaved and humbled by a cruel
magician so this too follows the Oscar
Wilde story that it was inspired by but
as original as this folklore entry was
it's also the reason we had to give it a
low loss score as there was a lot of
overlap between the folklore and the
boss's supposed law within the game
coming up with your own law is important
but while I would have liked to see some
deviation from the folklore as well as
maybe some more overt Elden ring
references this entry was brilliant in
almost every other way and absolutely
deserves a place in the top 10 coming in
at number 8
dhannu the puppet knight by Celeste the
first thing everyone I show this two
notices with this piece is that striking
posture that curvature of the body which
is mirrored in the curvature of the
weapon and also in the curvature of the
crown as well which is in itself a
subtle Eldon Ring logo reference
Dhanu stands this way to reinforce that
she is in fact a sort of puppet a vessel
crafted by a talented Smith to protect
something precious the Smith's name was
Galan and he was the craftiest man in
the world capable of making or repairing
anything made of wood and iron every
Kingdom every ruler wanted him by their
side yet one day he
with a shiny thing that he found on a
battlefield and if you ever saw him
after that the thing obsessed him and
every day every hour his hammer pounded
away at something but no one ever knew
what and to hide this shiny little thing
he locked himself behind an impenetrable
door and then brought the puppet knight
to life to help protect the shiny thing
that had destroyed his life when you
stumble upon this arena by the Smiths
door Don who will walk towards you
acting disinterested and then attacking
all at once with brutal combos until she
fades back into apathy at 10% health the
puppet knight breaks her present weapon
into pieces revealing four arms behind
her cape she gets down on all fours and
attacks at once with the shards of her
broken weapon interestingly you're not
actually supposed to fight back in this
phase you just enjoy her onslaught for
12 seconds and she will fall back defeat
it this piece received excellent scores
for originality and also law but it was
held back by its folklore inspirations
as they were only limited to the
concepts of a sort of legendary Smith
that you hear about in Norse legends I
would have also loved to see the Smith
since he features prominently in the law
but perhaps not seeing him is
intentional since he is in hiding after
all regardless congratulations to
Celeste truly of all the thousand
entries that we received this next one
might be the most evocative and it
manages it all with a single image this
is Herne the hunter described as a
set-piece boss similar to the serpent
God in sec you know I take this to mean
that he's not supposed to be defeated
only run from which I'm glad kayo added
because I was almost about to criticize
the boss for looking undefeatable your
goal in this place kayo
says is to reach this protected oak tree
but as you get closer to it you notice
enormous arrows flying past in the
forest and then later you catch glimpses
of this enormous thing flitting between
distant trees eventually it becomes a
full-on chase with this thing pulling
its unwieldly limbs and weapons through
the trees behind you
Herne the hunter is a local legend from
the forests of Berkshire likely inspired
by other gods such as the Celtic God so
who knows who you can see in his horns
or even the Norse god Odin whose
features you can see in his single eye
additionally there are powerful Elden
ring references here like the fact that
it's an open world encounter clearly and
also the multiple arm motif that we saw
in the trailer I love that there's a
character hiding here not only for scale
but to reinforce the fact that you're
meant to hide and run from this boss and
I also like the multiple arms because
it's a common mistake to see multiple
arms carrying like tons of weapons which
wouldn't really work from a gameplay
point of view but this boss has a bow
and a couple of swords that's the right
amount I think so while it lacks a
little bit in presentation and the law
is largely lifted from the original
story of Hern this is an incredible
entry and it's well deserving of 7th
place but what if I told you that
gameplay could be described through
music this is oders ring by Ricardo
amico and today he delivers something
that's so artistic so ambitious that it
honestly almost exists outside of the
competition the boss is called Oda and
it's a fight in two phases fought to the
tune of a giant harp that odor plays
throughout because his entry isn't just
a boss is a symbolic depiction
of the boss fight' said to music than
Ricardo himself has composed for example
look over to the right every time you're
about to hear is actually the boss
attacking with blasts of wind
[Music]
[Music]
this boss takes inspiration from Richard
Wagner's Ring a 16-hour long opera cycle
that tells an epic story inspired by
Germanic and Norse myths in Wagner's
mythology Oda is the world's wisest
woman and she knows all of the stories
that have ever been told and all that
are yet to be in Ricardo's
interpretation Oda is a fate weaving
boss able to control your movement and
even your characters stats to shape your
story to her liking speaking of that a
bit of an easter egg is the runic text
around the edges that read I will pull
the strings and down your curtain rings
and who are you to tempt your fate go
which way my winds blow for if you don't
I will pull the rings of fate and so on
the fight takes place on the back of a
giant Lindwurm which is essentially an
ancient Norwegian version of a wire then
you yourself fight on the back of a
chariot chasing down Oda as she tries to
escape you in phase one we mentioned the
wind blasts in the music earlier and in
this phase she also creates a fog that
requires you to listen for where she is
and then you also have to deflect air
streams that whip down upon your
character none of this does damage in
this phase by the way it just slows down
your chase so she just wants to get rid
of you here until it's too late of
course for in phase 2 the boss sheds a
tear and then transforms horrific Lea
into a living Orchestra now you're the
one being chased and she rains hell down
upon you
she peppers you with stat altering
arrows a huge wolf will leap at you from
the clouds a swarm of crows dived down
and sometimes she even summons the
Lindwurm itself to attack you from the
clouds you can hear all of this and more
in the music itself which you really
should to go and listen to over on
Ricardo's art station where you can just
sit quietly with this piece and give it
the attention it deserves because it
really is a masterpiece
Ricardo won last year's prosthetic art
challenge and as a result of that I've
started working with him since then of
commissioning other projects so in order
to avoid bias this entry was not judged
by me but if I had to guess it received
sixth place because the gameplay
concepts are a little bit incompatible
with from software games and they're
also missing some references to Elden
ring while it really can't be judged by
the same criteria as the rest the
technical skill the originality the law
and the presentation here they're off
the charts and Ricardo should be
incredibly proud of the true art that
he's created imagine aimlessly exploring
a coastline in the open world of Elden
ring when you come across piles of loot
swords and armor discarded at the
coastline you start picking it up and as
the world begins to darken with the
setting of the Sun you look over to the
horizon and something catches your eye
it's the silhouette of a man
effortlessly standing upright in the
depths of the reflective waters and it
would be impossible to just ignore that
right because he's just a man how
threatening could he be so you strip off
your heavier armor to move better in the
water like the other dead warriors
before you did and you come to stand in
the depths next to him expecting to talk
this is the knockin who in Scandinavian
folklore is described as this beautiful
young man who tricks women to jump into
the water with him to drown them and as
you get closer
something huge grabs you from underwater
tearing you down below where the fight
begins this boss is inspired by seculars
underwater controls which is genius
because I
from developed this system for use in
Elden ring as well and as amazing as the
underwater combat system in sekito was
it never really had a boss that did it
justice if you think about it but the
knockin does Gregory provided these
graphics for the fight something that
really helps you visualize it in a fully
3d space he says that all of these
attacks are foreshadowed by gestures
that the humanoid figure up top makes
there are also new mechanics here like
needing to ditch your armor to swim
faster you need to come up for air
periodically and you can also increase
your dodge range if you find an
underwater surface to kick off of if you
die to this boss there's even an
animation whereby you're absorbed into
him adding to the collection of failed
heroes whose arms are outstretched and
their faces are captured baring their
final expressions
Gregory's entry is a masterclass in
originality and it was a joy to imagine
this boss actually existing in olden
ring it made me realize that Elden rings
bosses by virtue of the open world will
feel like they really live in the world
compared to a lot of the other from
software bosses because now that it's an
open world it's not just about how the
boss is designed how we encounter it is
also important to bosses like these that
are really high standard for from
software to meet and this really does
help us to imagine what's possible so
here's another entry that was fully
inspired by the open world to the point
where I'm awarding it a shared third
place with the entry that's to follow it
this is Pesta she's the Crone of death
or at least that's what she wants you to
think in the 14th century the Black
Plague ravaged humankind in Norway they
called it pester a norwegian word for
the pandemic but also a personification
of it since it had a biological cause
and that was incomprehensible to people
at the time the plague took the form of
an old woman said to be Ashley
faced and carrying a broom or a rake and
it's this folklore that Christian has
pulled from for his boss fight in his
vision of Eldon Ring the character will
stumble upon towns and villages only to
realize that they've been decimated by
the plague and just like the townsfolk
of 14th century Norway the NPC's blame
pester and they implore you to seek her
out and kill her to end her rampage
so in this really open world style you
follow the trail of death and decay
until you track her down because she's a
wandering boss and you confront her and
start the fight the battle has three
phases but they don't play out like
you'd expect in the first her movements
are slow and stiff with long ranged
attacks of magic corruption poisonous
smoke and rats in the second phase she
increases in size and desperation with
these disturbing frantic attacks however
astute players will notice here that her
hair has become more graceful and divine
a hint for her final phase and her true
identity the third phase comes after the
full depletion of pests as health bar
when a soft and elegant voice is heard
rats transform into crows and ravens and
the music begins again her rake reveals
a spear within it and a new HP bar
appears this time belonging to the
Phantom Queen that name is a translation
of a name that belongs to another Celtic
goddess the more agooo a shape-shifting
Celtic goddess of war fate and death the
more ogres folklore is murky and she
takes many forms and indeed she took
many forms in this competition as so
many artists decided to depict her in
different ways however this was the only
entry that incorporated her deceptive
form into the story of the boss fight
itself because it was the more agooo the
Phantom Queen in phase 3 who was
creating the plague all along and
becoming hated as Pesta who she was in
phase 1 instead of as her true self
that's amazing so the only entries that
received a 10 for folklore were those
that blended stories together in
true from software fashion and on top of
that this piece also made incredible
references to olden ring and while I
would have loved some visual
environmental details it scored highly
in every category and
it owns an undeniable place in the top
three
looking at Christians art station we
realized that much of his work has this
style that's consistent with his entry
and that's something I think is
important in an artist because his work
is very unique and recognizable as a
result he's an aspiring digital artist
from Tampa Florida who's currently
interested in contract or freelance work
so the project needs an artist with
inspired designs and an incredible
creative flair and this is your guy but
it was actually impossible not to put
this next piece in the top three as well
because well look at it
if I told you this was official concept
art Ferelden ring you'd probably believe
me this is visceral the black winged
Valkyrie by Jonathan Lee he says that
the goal here was to make this boss feel
intimidating yet majestic which he
achieves with sharp upward angles and
striking silhouettes but then he also
tried to display a depraved descent here
which he achieves with blackened wings a
crude helmet ragged clothing and D
saturated colors in Nordic folklore the
Valkyrie were these warriors who served
odin there were women who escorted the
souls of those who died bravely in
battle to the halls of Valhalla in
Jonathan's story however visceral was
once the glory of the Valkyrie Legion
and protector of the olden ring
tragically falling from grace when the
ring was shattered for centuries
she was outcast forgotten but then one
day the echoes of the Ring called for
her service once again but this time not
as a protector but as a destroyer
Valkyries were a really common entry but
Jonathan's rises above it's design is
perfectly compatible with the high
fantasy veiled and ring the technical
skill here is flawless and the
presentation could be straight out of a
from software design works if you browse
through Jonathan's art station you may
spot his entry last year too
prosthetic art competition another entry
that placed within the top 10 with this
clean concept art like design Jonathan
is an artist in San Jose who's currently
looking for work so if your project
needs an artist with insane technical
and presentation skills as well then
this is your guy and man if you thought
three and four were difficult to place
wait until you see one and two coming in
second by hairsbreadth is the Nikhil AVI
Patera of the full onshore by Andre show
stuck the Nikhil avi is a monster from
Acadian mythology the nastiest of all
the demons in Scotland's Northern Isles
it's breath was thought to wilt crops
and sicken livestock and the creature
was held responsible for droughts and
epidemics on land
despite being predominantly a sea
dweller the technical skill in this main
image might be the strongest in the
competition you can see the sea spray
from the ocean you can feel the momentum
of the clash between the two riders and
even the background complements the
shape of the main clash in the
foreground it's striking it's disturbing
it's atmospheric and I've only just
started describing the first image on
the second page we see a breakdown of
the bosses arena which consists of
deepwater shallow water and Beach all
having varying effects on the players
movements which by the way is largely on
horseback putting you on even footing
with this Lovecraftian nightmare as you
gallop around the arena you have to be
sure to avoid the bosses plague breath
which has locked off certain parts of
the arena and from this hazard
come little undead minions raised from
the corpses that were on the beach
before you were there in his first face
the nokia Livi fights with long ranged
attacks and tries to avoid melee
encounters with melee attacks that
attempt to sort of create distance
between you both this is the phase where
you have to avoid the plague breath and
there's also another mechanic whereby if
you aim the camera at the boss when it
has its eye exposed the curse status
begins to be inflicted upon you
requiring you to look away as certain
intervals with your camera and if you
get close to the boss you can even cut
off its tail which gives you the spine
lash whip a weapon that has a high
potential to damage the wielder as well
I love that each of these weapons comes
with its own law and description and
image as well about how you hold it
damaging the boss reveals that the
humanoid and the horse actually have
separate health bars and the phase two
that you're about to enter depends on
which one you defeated first defeat the
rider first and we interface to a
against the horse which dislocates its
jaw and extends its tail for melee
combat if you're still mounted you can
actually try and get the boss to crash
into barricades or rocks and if you're
dismounted you'll have to counter attack
while it's jaw is open defeat this phase
of the boss and you'll receive its
dissected leg was a great hammer which
retains the elapsed anger that carried
the tireless beast however if you
defeated the horse in phase one then we
enter phase 2b against the humanoid who
starts the fight with this almost
unavoidable dismounting grab attack from
here he uses his long ranged homing
missiles or his long arms for melee
combat depending on whether you're a
fighter or a caster additionally if you
make the mistake of fighting him in the
ocean then he actually has a grab attack
where he uses these freakishly long arms
to hold you under the water and drown
you defeat the boss in this phase and
you'll receive a staff made of its I
which strengthens undead magic and can
be used to inflict the same curse effect
that the boss used against you the
artist even took replayability into
account and if you gather all three of
the weapons by visiting new game+ or by
trading with other players then you can
receive the gwad and more an enormous
glaive with a special attack that mounts
the player temporarily on the knuckle of
e itself this insane entry was the work
of russian artist andre who
unfortunately has no social media or
portfolio to show off for this
competition he says that he participated
in this competition out of pure
enthusiasm alone and that if you would
like to you can contact him
via the email address on screen and the
winner with an entry that excels in
originality compatibility with Eldon
ring folklore and unique law is the
Drowned of C by Jonas Mueller the
village of C lay near a swamp next to a
lake the drowned bodies of missing
people were frequently found in the lake
but the villagers thought this was
merely part of living near the swamp but
over the years something changed an
unnatural amount of people started to
get swallowed for something terrible
lived in the water and in time would
devour the entire village
this law is excellent it's succinct and
intriguing the Drowned is inspired by
two beings first by the kelpie which is
a supernatural water horse that was said
to drown those who try to ride it and
second by the slough spirits of the
Restless dead of people who are
unwelcome in other heaven or hell as
mentioned earlier the only pieces to get
full points for folklore were those that
seamlessly combine multiple inspirations
and the space is one of them because
something entirely original has been
created here as a result and it's
something that just looks as if it's
straight out of a Souls game right
you wouldn't blink twice if I told you
Eldon rink had a swamp area which it
will probably just imagine that you're
exploring this shallow swamp
when this damned thing closed its way up
to meet you for that reason it gets full
points for compatibility with Eldon ring
as well I also love that he took the
multiple arm motif to the next level for
it's the arms of the Drowned
that helped the beings swing that
enormous mace that is designed to really
look like it was dredged up from the
bottom of a swamp my only wish is that
mounted combat could have been mentioned
since the piece features the water horse
in its design combat has two phases
first where you fight the warrior
sitting atop his horse as the spirits
keep up that appearance of fighting like
a human and then in Phase two the
Drowned becomes enraged corpses begin to
float to the surface of the lake and
they'll attack you if you get too close
while the spirits abandon all pretense
of being a man on horseback and instead
throw everything at you
it's movement becomes unnatural and hard
to predict as it extends the range of
its attacks by chaining together corpses
and summoning corpses from below the
lake to jut upwards like the firestorm
pyromancy because hundreds of people
have been drowned over the years and the
creature has become really really strong
as a result it's so difficult to find a
single fault with this entry and I
really have no other choice but to
awarded first place in this boss design
competition Jonas is an environmental
artist at Rice Games and that company is
lucky to have the guy so please do me a
favor and check out his portfolio and
social media down below and please join
me in following not just Jonas but
everyone who participated and put their
art up for display in this competition
thank you everyone for this incredible
work these are some of the most talented
people in the industry and if you're an
employer or if you're a Commissioner of
those who create great art then please
look no further because this is your
list this is their resume but it goes
further than the top ten honestly
way way further to many of the odd
thousand people who participated because
how can I not mention the veiled sisters
of the eastern mounds by Andrew mironov
inspired by Gaelic and the Morrigan or
the Luke Thief by Rex Beck who
transforms in his second phase in a
flurry of crows there was Ogun the son
faced who attacks with his voice which
was incredibly unique and he was
inspired by the Celtic God of speech
there was naman of the slain sisters
this interpretation of the Eldon Ring
Valkyrie in the trailer but in a crow
like monster form a guy called Spence
even contributed this Lovecraftian
creature in a sort of glowing ink that I
had never seen before there were so many
entries that had hours upon hours and
hours of work in them and it's so
difficult not to include them all
prominently in the video because
so many people deserve it honestly but
really there's more to this than the
judgement of myself and a couple of
other artists this is about challenging
yourself and improving your art and for
a lot of you I know that this
competition helped you towards that goal
even if you didn't make it in the top 10
many of you I'll be reaching out to in
the coming weeks to work on commissions
if you're open and I encourage everyone
in my audience watching now do this as
well
Commission people beyond the top 10
scour through the imager link in the
description showing the top 100 follow
the social media or just go to their
portfolios and check them out if you
have any ideas for future art
competitions let me know in the comments
below it's something I do because in the
absence of Elton ring news at the game
Awards this artwork has helped us to
imagine Elton ring and I like to imagine
that it might inspire some other artists
to pick up the craft so shuts out to the
Eldon Ring subreddit for inspiring this
competition with their fake floor thank
you for watching and thank you for
participating speaking of incredible art
have you guys ever heard of the game
called blasphemous it feels like every
month I would get tweets telling me that
I have to play this game as a Souls fan
and now that it's super cheap as a part
of this month's Humble choice bundle I'm
so glad I gave it a shot
so like the souls games you're supposed
to play blasphemous really methodically
every enemy has a weakness and a rhythm
that's yours to exploit and what's more
the game's steadily builds upon your
torment adding environmental effects and
hazards that require you to modify your
behavior around them as well overcoming
a section eventually becomes something
you're really proud of and I'm always
looking forward to the next section that
crushes me because I know that when I do
defeat it I'm gonna beat it in style so
if this game is for anyone it's for you
guys and you can get this game and to
others for just $14.99 with the
subscription to Humble choice and the
price of this subscription which gives
you more than the game by the
is cheaper than the price of the actual
game on Steam a humble choice is
basically the new humble monthly it's a
way to get a ton of games support
charity and support developers as well
with your monthly subscription this is a
subscription that also affords you 20%
off at their store you get instant
access to over 90 games in their trove
and you also get up to 9 curated games
every month
so it's always been a great deal and
it's a pretty wholesome company that I'm
always proud to support so please click
the link down below in the description
to get that deal it expires on the 3rd
of January so get in quick thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time